joining us now with reaction
editor-in-chief life set Fox News
contributor nationally syndicated radio
host Laura Ingraham you're laughing
well I listen to you and I'm like these
are the golden oldies of the Clintons I
mean you didn't hit web Hubbell or you
know Broderick or you could have was
just all of that but it's all a lie
she's now making money off a bunch of
suckers that are buying a book that's
full of lies and fake news I think she
believes it take cameras to the book I
mean that's what it's her staff should
have done before they released it I was
thinking of the old quote from Teddy
Roosevelt that if you could kick the
person in the pants most responsible for
your own troubles you wouldn't sit for a
month and Hillary Hillary Clinton has to
think about that she even Eleanor
Roosevelt her her idol talked about how
we shape our own lives we we make our
own decisions and ultimately we're
responsible until we die for those
decisions in our own fate and yet every
turn
whether it's going back to you know 1998
and Monica Lewinsky all the way up
through the Clinton scandals of the
Clinton Foundation it's never ever ever
the Clinton's fault and I think that
refusal to take really pretty much any
personal responsibility of any note is
part of the reason why Trump Trump won
because people are just kind of sick of
that type of politics Trump Trump is not
a someone who's gonna apologize a lot
that's not who he is but he did expose
the Clintons for what they do and who
they are and I think that second debate
Shawn member the second debate where he
you know he stood next to her and he had
all those women who who it was creepy he
was within 10 feet of her yeah and all
the women who Bill Clinton had abused
and in in Broderick and Paula Jones and
all the rest and he said you're talking
about you know some locker room talk you
know that I regret and I'm sorry for
yeah that's bad but what about what
happened to these women and he put he
called out the Clintons for what most
Republicans in public office were afraid
to do which is their utter disregard for
the norms of human behavior
and and how most public servants treat
the the oath of office which is with
great you know with great respect and
great reverence not the revolving door
of influence that we saw at the State
Department so you nailed it in your
monologue all right let me ask you this
because Mitch McConnell said our
expectations have been really really
high that after you know begging for the
House the Senate in the White House they
you know and after seven and a half
years expecting health care that was
really unfair of us to expect the job
done now he's say in the tax bill may go
into next year now my first reaction is
one of anger and feeling of betrayal
it's that's rightful anger the people
expect action if Mitch McConnell cannot
get this done and I know they're meeting
in the White House tonight I think
they're having dinner but if he can't
get this done with a house in Republican
hands debt obviously the Senate in the
presidency then I think it's time for
him and a lot of his colleagues to go
into a different line of work they're
just not all that good contrary to what
we've heard at politics
so maybe Mitch McConnell either rides
off into the sunset does something in
Kentucky maybe can run a bourbon company
or something down there and and leave
politics to people like Donald Trump who
can actually cut deals when necessary
and get results for the American people
because so far you know they've they've
they've given us a bunch of goose eggs
here we've gotten gotten almost nothing
from the Republicans and and Donald
Trump's sick of it so he's gonna cut
deals if he has to to move the ball down
the field and Republicans can publicans
could actually build out a movement that
would sustain this party for decades
Shawn if they actually followed the
America first made America great agenda
they blow the party party you know into
into new areas of the country be great
you know Kennedy did it and Reagan did
it when Reagan went from 70 to 28
percent top marginal tax rate in his
years as president revenues doubled and
we created 20 million new jobs if we go
from the highest corporate tax cut
corporate tax rate in the industrialized
world to the lowest if we go for a
middle-class tax cut repatriation of
multinational 7 brackets to 3 and then
add energy jobs we can have that success
and more I don't think that's that
even if you have a Senate lunch the
Senate barbershop the Senate dining room
and the Senate smoke room and brandy
shop you ought to be able to find an
hour or two to get that done and and
look they they find money for all sorts
of garbage on Capitol Hill I mean they
they allocate billions of dollars that
frankly we never see hide nor hair of
again and it's it's it's not to what end
and in this point we have a chance it's
the first time in 30 years to revitalize
the American economy for a new
generation of Americans long after Mitch
McConnell is gone long after we're gone
this could actually sustain the country
as China continues to bear down on us
continues to outperform continues to
grow its military we need an economy
that works for the average person and
we've tried the other way we've tried
globalization on steroids and that's
made a lot of people rich but it hasn't
made the middle rich and the Forgotten
man and women who showed up to vote for
Trump and Donald Trump has to keep those
people in mind as he does these
negotiations Laura Ingraham good to see
it thank you